into the corner Jamie Dale moved in fired in
a recent deal from Anaheim into the high slide
it came and Lon out stopped that one and a good
stop on kkny kept Alive by Dale again back for
jagar zamolo's been terrific that got blocked by
Fisher that one sted he didn't let on but it he
felt it Dale played that one ahead he scored his
first goal Tuesday on the power play here they
come in again failing with the chance and a save
there by lion Justin Hall cleared it Ryan paling
on it again with the lead pass in for Tyson
Forester right in on goal and set up backand
high as a member of the Flyers he made his debut
against Detroit here's Raymond low down in front
Pon back for gosp for l oh hit the crossbar wow
pretty good Puck Movement by Detroit and Lin in
the a deep slot as one go off the iron look at
Philadelphia lined up in front holy meel that
one off a chest sacrificed by that group second
unit will come out gos bear leads the Red Wing
with high power play points nearly caught one
up R in their own goal right there the brinka
knocked down at the line and a good defensive
play by Noah Kates tipped in front line for
to hold [Applause] on played by fabri ahead for
fisers the other four for Detroit change blocker
saved by Arison lead Fe for Hathaway that got
knocked off his stick by Hall then Li in the
save and he'll gather it back in and hold on he's
he likes players honesty and uh there are many
examples of that on this plier team right in front
and a good save there by lion it gets knocked away
lead pass here for to [Applause] brinka cam York
played with the Michigan Wolverines from 2019 to
2021 number eight for the Flyers on the wing
for lin looks across to break it oh boy good
piece of that right in front the Metro but
they're only three points ahead of Detroit so
that wild card situation whether you're in there
or not is wide open a cross for Pon in deep with
it patri rer save by erson Lin Raymond to Brink it
wman shot by Raymond rebound L
and good save harison Baria Ian
Hall collide thereby again good save Down Low by
lions then the RS will be off for a while it's
the All-Star break in the by week that's a good
thing nice 10day break there'll be 50 games
in when it's all said and done and that's why
minimum they have to win two of the next three
starting with [Applause] tonight and having lost
to Dallas the other night and you get greedy
and want 10 out of 10 but uh I'd say if you're
looking at a five-game home stand and you go8
out of 10 that would be really something Lucas
Raymond def Frink cuts to the middle and a
shot C blocked Raymond on it again fires one
good save oh they score lurin he's got a 10
game point streak and his 20th [Music] goal
all set up by De Bren who just came off the
bench fresh Rond took the shot through some
traffic and it's a good save and I don't think
he could do no that puck hit the goal tender I
don't think he saw it and Dylan Lin on one
hop goes right up under the crossbar to get
the first goal of this game that's a way
to Let Her Go Dylan how about that Dylan
Lin at 199 Comer at 99 cop at 99 pulled out
front and a save there by lion off the near
post brought Away by wman rale
defended saved by Arison Puck
to the corner Tyson Forest are
going for it BR it comes for
ma Larin dumps it into the left wing offensive
Corner played back by parody gave it up to
grean De cider off the leg he scores what a
deflection that was CER they're happy for him
it's been a while his first in 20 [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] [Music] games oh boy oh boy
that thing had eyes all the way and went off a
stick and that you know there is the negative
the shot blocking right there pair of 14s
in back of the net as he gets tied up by
[Applause] fabri Flyers control the
draws zamula that shot gets blocked
doesn't get out though Noah Kates is on
it saved by lion loose in front of the
net comes back for zamula so the Flyers
go to their second power [Applause] play
right in on lion to save off Cera
for Joel farab shot blocked by
Petri Red Wings change their d as Ras
M gets it in the halfway point of this
game Red Wings with two in the second
R mus on a steal back for cop he scores
goal number 100 for Andrew [Music] cop
short handed goal all set up by Michael
rasm it was a line change r m did all the work
the fers are too soft top came on the ice for
lin I believe and there's no flyer over there in
the whole left side there's three of them on rash
hon he comes up with the puck and toop just walks
right into it in his wheelhouse and rips it good
job on cachua kept in by sealer connect me with a
shot loose Puck and fr oh hit the cross bar oh and
then a diving stop by wman as ainson couldn't
bury it after cider to annihilated a couple of
them here's this chip off the bar there and then
Walman on Atkinson that puck was going back into
the grease area that's a little close for comfort
still half a game to play here and the players
know how to come back we know that yes on the last
time here we know that and you know if this score
stays relatively the same going into the third you
can bet as you look at that craziness Around the
Net then Pon finished his check picked up by
Luke cell through his skates what a play in
on goal and going why lion held his ground
penalty up coming here to Brink it for spraw
went to his backand what a chance again
for him to fire it he's got an amazing
shot sanheim played back in front of the goal
oh wow and what a save by Li wow on halfway
somehow he found it one of them can and it
it ended up right in his glove look at that
oh oh jeez wow pathway right there off his the
blade of his stick and right into the catching
glove the Trapper of Alex [Applause] lion as
the Red Wings win it over Philadelphia three
to nothing Dylan L and the game winning
goal Alex lion a terrific night 29 saves